I think games are a powerful medium in others.
Their impact becomes more powerful when events revolve around reality
And about the events of our daily lives.
This is what we tried to do in Bury me, my Love.
I worked as a journalist for 10 years and I was passionate about video games all my life
One day, I had an idea
It's about creating video games about real life.
From this idea, she specialized in video game development.
One day, I read an article in Le Monde
The article was written by a French journalist called "Lucy Solier"
It was about a young Syrian immigrant named "Dana"
And continued contact with family members thanks to her smartphone.
Nowadays, most migrants acquire smart phones
This is not for the sake of luxury, but for communication with
Friends and family in the same way
Which I communicate with my friends or my mother.
I was very touched by this article, so I saw
They fit a lot as an idea for a realistic game.
So I met the journalist who helped us
To communicate with Dana, which we reported
Much in developing a realistic game involves an impressive message.
Did you see the boat inside
Or were there too many people inside?
There were so many people, but the smugglers organized our way of sitting
We could not stand. Only managed to see people and sky
And how far we are from Turkey.
This must have been terrible.
After Lucy and Dana collaborated with us, I realized we would have it
Valuable information that enables us to correctly recount the events of this story.
The story of Bury me, my Love about the couple "Nour" and "glory"
Who split because Noor wanted to leave Syria
And access to safety in Europe, while Majd could not take her.
Mobile phone is their only way to communicate with each other.
Will begin to play the role of "glory" to provide help and advice to "Nour"
In the best possible way so that it can reach its destination safely.
We took great advantage of what Dana told us and drew inspiration from her
We wanted to tell thousands of stories
And the reference to thousands of places where thousands of people migrate
From different places to reach safety.
I was also very impressed when I visited the refugee center
To learn the details of the lives of these refugees.
No doubt, we were thrilled when we won the Google Play Independent Gaming Contest
I felt the gratitude to all the members of the team and everyone
Participate in the development of the game.
The most important reason for my happiness is that the game carries a message.
If you create a game that simulates real life on highly sensitive subjects
You will inevitably find out who is appreciated by experienced experts
Who will tell you that they are dazzled by your new idea.
I hope that other developers will know that and follow the same path.
I do not know whether the game has contributed to changing the attitude of others toward immigrants.
I am not a humanitarian activist, but I hope that immigrants will receive the sympathy and care of everyone.
My first goal is to create a game, tell a story, and not change people's attitudes towards certain topics.